pop
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
championnats d'europe de patinage
artistique à garmisch partenkirchen en
allemand depuis la danse par couple est
admise dans les épreuves internationales
les britanniques dorine dénis et cornet
jones domine de fort loin tous leurs
adversaires
cette année encore il surclasse tous les
autres coûts
avec les allemands marais qu'à kehl
youth et un sur gundam l'heure on passe
enfin aux choses sérieuses et à dire
pour véritable patinage artistique plus
athlétique - miyem plus sportif et plus
spectaculaire que la danse
[Musique]
les deux allemands déjà champion
d'europe conservent leur titre d'extrême
justesse cependant le penser alain
giletti a enfin retrouvé le titre qu'il
avait abandonnée il ya deux ans aux
tchèques parole divine
[Musique]
il est il n'a pas trouvé d'adversaire à
sa taille si l'on peut dire puisqu'il
est petit mais grand et son talent comme
vous pouvez le voir
[Applaudissements]
a alger le camp retranché d'hyères est
devenu chantier rue charles péguy et rue
michelet on a enlevé les vieux rails de
tramway en même temps que les derniers
pas vrai les deux rues seront désormais
houde rené
c'est au milieu de cette remise en ordre
que sont arrivés de paris pour une autre
remise en marbre les ministres de
l'intérieur de la justice et des armes
et compte accueillir monsieur de
l'ouvrier et le général challe
[Musique]
je suis messmer ministre des armées
depuis la veille a tenu à marquer son
passage d'une visite aux blessés de
l'hôpital mayo et en particulier aux
gendarmes mobiles victimes de la
fusillade du 24 janvier
[Applaudissements]
cependant la vie a repris son cours dans
la ville principal bastion de
l'insurrection
les facultés ont rouvert leurs portes
aux étudiants loyer n'emportant une
petite formalité
les marchés ont retrouvé leurs va et
vient quotidien
et huit jours après la fin du camp
retranché la circulation a repris sur le
macadam tout neuf du centre de la ville
sortie de la fièvre alger revis
[Musique]
oh
à
cette année c'est cela varsovie des
quartiers neufs des murs neufs des toits
cette ville est toute jeune elle a 15
ans il avait fallu huit siècles pour
faire cette varsovie défunte qu'on peut
encore chérir à travers la brume des
souvenirs mais les souvenirs nous livre
aussi la sombre vision d'une ville qui
fut pour un temps de l'histoire la ville
la plus détruite du monde c'est à cette
vision que se superposent la capitale
d'aujourd'hui cette ville neuve ou 230
mille appartements ont été construits ou
un varsoviens sur trois vit dans une
maison neuve
ils sont plus d'un million c'est par ce
biais c'est par ce biais on ne se
souviendra pas sans surprise devant ces
silhouettes de l'atmosphère de deuil qui
assombrissaient les visages au lendemain
de la libération et dont on connaîtra à
nouveau cette espèce de parenté qui
selon les voyageurs unis c'est la guerre
à l'atmosphère des rues de paris celle
des rues de varsovie
[Musique]
plus d'un million de vars bien tout ce
monde aux heures de pointe
empli les tramways au delà de leur
contenance car varsovie n'est pas
seulement une capitale politique et
spirituelle où s'expriment avec le plus
de charme et de vérité le sentiment
polonais elle est aussi le plus grand
centre industriel du pays cette
industrie elle existait déjà autrefois
mais la reconstruction d'un sextuplé
jack faubourg a vu s'élever ses usines
et varsovie compte parmi les grands
centres métallurgique du pays avec ses
fonderie spécialisée dans la fabrication
de haute précision
[Musique]
pourquoi nous voici dans le quartier de
l'automobile le grenelle de varsovie où
l'on fabrique bon an mal an quelque
12000 voiture et 40000 motocyclette
en attendant la chaîne de scooter
la seconde en importance des industries
varsovienne et celle des postes radios
et des téléviseurs ainsi que celles qui
s'intéressent à d'autres branches du
domaine de l'électronique 100000
téléviseur sortent annuellement de ces
ateliers
certains ateliers se consacre à la
fabrication des vals ou de radios des
tubes électroniques et des transistors à
la finition de cet appareillage aux
proportions infinitésimale dont
certaines pièces ont la grosseur d'une
tête d'épinglé
voici ailleurs le quartier des
polisseurs et des fabrications d'optique
dans lesquels varsovie s'est fait une
place
[Musique]
et voici le quartier des fabriques d'où
sortent la plupart des lampes et des
tubes fluorescents qu'utilise le pays
c'est à la lumière de ses tubes que nous
reconnaîtrons une varsovie nocture
varsovie s'allument dans toutes les rues
s'inscrivent les petites constellation
vibrante des magasins des brasseries et
des dancing varsovie danse toujours
derrière ses murs tout n'est comme
autrefois
[Musique]
la rentrée d'edith piaf elle est au bout
d'une longue convalescence
car pour la chanteuse que nous avons
retrouvé au cours d'une promenade au
bois entre deux séjours à la clinique
il ne peut pas ne pas y avoir de rentrée
il ne peut pas ne pas y avoir à nouveau
la rampe et le public en face c'est ce
qu'elle nous a dit chez elle entre sa
compositrice préféré marguerite monnot
et le jeune peintre doublage d'avis
je vais bientôt chanter dans trois
semaines puisque chanter c'est ma vie je
ne peux pas m'empêcher de santé et je
ressens très très vite pour vous
[Musique]
hamon
ce qui est
ans
[Applaudissements]
ah ah
mais j'étais
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]